we're about to have a lot of fun viewing
the world premiere of the restoration of
the uncensored version of Howard
Hughes's
1932 film [ __ ] of the air as you saw in
the Academy close-up piece the
production code was newly established
when [ __ ] of the air was released in
1932 led by the conservative will Hays
the code was away from the movie
industry to improve wholesomeness and
purity in motion pictures during
tonight's screening anytime there is a
censored moment you'll be able to follow
along with the assistance of a little
icon that will be placed in the bottom
right hand corner of the screen the cuts
vary from a single word a single line or
even a four-minute scene and when you
see these cuts you'll find the
violations of the code to be very tame
by modern standards you will also be
surprised to see what they did not
censor like lead actress Billy doves low
low low cut dresses which leave very
little to the imagination as the code
was not well established when the film
came out Howard Hughes and director Tom
Buckingham were able to sneak a lot past
the censors so what was removed and why
the cuts are well documented in the 139
page file of the production Co papers
held at the Academy's Margaret Herrick
library some of these are reproduced and
are available for viewing just outside
the theater here and they were made by
the amazing team at the library
including Jenny Warren Jo Ann Brad and
Joe if you miss them you can see them on
your way out as a key a key concern was
the lead actor lieutenant Roger Craig an
American pilot a member of the
censorship board refers to him as quote
a philandering and lecherous young man
who pursued rather lustful affairs
end quote the board was also concerned
by the betting system lieutenant Craig's
orderly Terry uses to keep track of the
lieutenant's conquests they were also
very concerned about scenes and involved
sexual innuendo or variable or visible
acts of physical canoe
aleem between lieutenant Craig and his
many conquests will Hays summarized his
concerns to Howard Hughes just before
production began in September 1931 Hays
felt that if the sinful themes were not
removed quote a large amount of a very
charming comedy which forms a part of
these sequences is likely to be tainted
for the consumption of the
unsophisticated audience
end quote despite an official appeal to
the censorship board by Hughes
approximately 12 minutes of picture and
sound was removed from the film but
tonight tonight we are presenting [ __ ]
of the air the way Howard Hughes
intended and all its glory and team
innuendo